[Applause]
sixteen days four countries 76
engagements and let's talk about all
those wardrobe changes what the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex ease royal tour seemed
like a dream and it's leaving us average
joes scratching our heads wondering how
we can score a vacation like the royals
for starters Meghan Harry hit up the
exotic locations of Australia Fiji Tonga
and New Zealand the cost alone and of
course they received the royal treatment
everywhere they went we're talking
practically being placed on a pedestal
being fed local grub and watching
performance after performance meant just
for them what's better than celebrating
the locals now let's talk about the
gifts the newlyweds dropped their
bombshell baby news just ten hours after
touching down in Australia their first
stop on the tour it rained gifts
throughout the entire two-week trip kind
of like their very own baby shower on
repeat they are inundated with gifts
there were poodles of flowers stuffed
animals galore and even swanky baby ugh
I'm sure those odd luck dates will be
going back to the rural nursery but
apparently it's the personalized gifts
like this handmade pasta necklace given
a meg by a little Australian boy that
the Royals like best the smaller the
better
she was really touched by receiving that
gift and actually she wore it later on
in the day that's because royal gift
protocol dictates what they can and
can't keep basically if an item is over
$300 in value it goes bye-bye and
there's no regifter now some of them
will be kept some of them will be stored
some of them may be donated to charity
and some of them may be handed on now as
for the gift that no value can be placed
on our favorite redheaded royal and his
admiration for his wife and unborn child
Harry publicly gushed every chance he
got
we also generally couldn't think of a
better place to announce the upcoming
baby
beard a boy or a girl I have been so
proud to be able to introduce my wife to
you and we have been so happy to be able
to celebrate the personal joy of our
newest addition with you all but we
aren't the only ones in love people fond
over the gorgeous couple at every stop
they made
now Megan harrier totally still in the
honeymoon phase
and while the trip was technically
business not pleasure the newlyweds
managed to sneak away for some private
time plus they gave us all the feels
with their regular PDA and overall
adorableness which included holding
hands
hiding under umbrellas and oh those
loving stares well you catch on quickly
as for another thing we love Megan's
outfit and there were many the mom-to-be
rocked to this gorgeous cream colored
gown from the Irish brand FEA on their
first night in Tonga the designer told
et quote we needed to remake it with
extra seam allowance we knew immediately
why this extra allowance was required
but mums the words
meg absolutely glowed while strolling
along Bondi Beach in a striped maxi
dress that perfectly hugged her bump she
even gave a nod to gal pal Serena
Williams sporting this loose-fitting
blazer from the tennis champs fashion
line of course the 145 dollar jacket
sold out but quite possibly her sweetest
fashion statement
a pair of butterfly earrings that were
once worn by Harry's mother Princess
Diana between the killer clothes the
destinations the gifts and all the love
Megan Harry's trip was truly regal now
where would you go if you could travel
like a royal
[Music]